welcome everybody in particular deputy
mayor of Sperling ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the fiber-to-the-home
conference it's my pleasure to welcome
you all here to Marseille and in
particular to our 14th annual
fiber-to-the-home conference before I go
into my speech per the guidance from
deputy mayor Sperling Marseille is
really genuinely a beautiful city if you
do get the opportunity later on after
the conference today or on your way to
fibration night later on please take
some time to take a look around the
harbour and the area it's really really
is very very beautiful and fantastic let
me begin by focusing a little bit on our
host country here France France is now a
member of a select Club of leaders in
the European fiber-to-the-home community
and it has risen to this prominent
position because its leaders in its
industry saw the advantages of
fiber-to-the-home
earlier than most because there was a
vision of what can be achieved with the
kind of capacity that only fiber can
deliver because there was recognition of
how important it will be for France to
be amongst the world digital leaders as
we approach the third decade of this
century because France knows that her
children will need this fiber foundation
in order to be able to compete
successfully on a global digital stage
the leadership demonstrated by France
and others have helped to ensure that
this vision is seeping into the European
Commission the Commission's recent
gigabit society communication makes a
strong start towards setting out a
vision a vision where we have very
widespread very high capacity networks
and they underpin the services to
society that will keep Europe at the
forefront of economic development
globally we've made huge progress in
moving forward however there is more to
do
which brings me to the points that I'd
like to touch on today firstly what is
our vision as fiber-to-the-home counsel
for Europe for the future why is fiber
the right infrastructure to achieve that
vision and where have we made progress
and what do we need to do next let me
begin with our vision many of the
potential uses of fiber to the home will
have significant impacts on society
foundational to digital innovation fiber
based societies will be equipped to deal
with the inevitable future growth
challenges as our world becomes
increasingly digital and as our
population construct continues to age
for me fibre to the home coupled with
the deep fibre that will be needed to
deliver on the gigabit society that
Europe is aspiring for is not about
generic Internet connectivity instead
it's about laying the foundation for
Europe's children to be able to compete
on a level playing field with their
global peers it's about removing the
barriers to digital innovation so Europe
can be positioned at the forefront of
the world's digital societies it's about
ensuring that Europe has the necessary
infrastructure to permit its industries
to take a leading position in the
emerging arenas of 5g autonomous
vehicles IOT smart grid and more
importantly all the future digital
industries that we haven't yet imagined
they need that future-proof
infrastructure for me this is about
building the bootstrap that will be
needed to kickstart Europe's economy and
ensure that we do not get relegated to
becoming the digital impoverished of
this third decade of this millennium
fiber-to-the-home infrastructures are
about inclusion they are about the
removal of barriers they are about
ensuring that our future innovators are
not restricted by the capabilities of
infrastructure from the last century
it's about ensuring our innovators are
free free to create the next googles or
Amazon's comfortable in the knowledge
that their national infrastructure can
scale to meet the needs that they'll
have to serve as a global economy
fiber-to-the-home infrastructures will
facilitate the transition of digital
workers to home working environments and
will ensure that the application of
telemedicine and care will have a
profound impact on how our aging
societies function in the future in the
case of home working this will bring
many benefits including the ability for
fiber rich communities to retain their
best and brightest rather than suffer
the continuity of traditional brain
drain to the large cities throughout the
world and this has direct positive
impacts ranging from positive GDP growth
in the region's to increases in property
prices to relief in traffic congestion
in our cities and towns while in
parallel allowing those that are faced
with long commutes to clawback
increasingly scarce personal time while
we all reduce our personal impact on the
environment in the case of home based
health applications d congestion of our
already overstretched health care
facilities along with substantial
financial savings to the state can be
anticipated however the largest benefits
will be for the users of these new
telemedicine and telecare services
permitted to remain safely within their
community for much longer as a
productive member of society quality of
life will be substantially improved for
all in parallel the duration of time
spent in elderly care facilities per
individual can be greatly reduced easing
the burden on already existing creaking
resources while in many cases providing
greater preservation of personal wealth
in so many fiber-rich examples the
benefit accruing to society goes
are beyond the direct economic benefits
invested are identified by the investor
community as one of the main recipients
society in general will be the main
beneficiary of the fiber networks being
built to this end it is critical
critically important that society's
understanding of these benefits is
increased and that society starts to
demand change if I look at the mid to
long term challenges facing Europe over
and above the challenges of our aging
population and the increased pressure
that they place on our health care
systems environmental sustainability and
lifting economic productivity must be
core to all government strategies
fiber-to-the-home networks can help to
deliver or enable a significant part of
the solution to each of these challenges
fiber-to-the-home infrastructure is the
capacity to transform public services
like education and government services
but it relies on the enablement of the
right infrastructure to deliver the
appropriate services the public sector
is the perfect anchor tenant for such
networks but it needs to use its power
its power to help move the market and it
can only do that by committing to the
change that is needed changes that are
needed to raise educational standards
while simultaneously increasing the
availability and reducing the cost of a
world-class education for all of
Europe's citizens changes needed to
offset the costs increases driven by our
aging population while simultaneously
improving the quality of life for our
elder citizens changes needed to
eradicate the barriers to innovation by
our digital natives
so that Europe can take lead a
leadership role in the world's digital
future this will involve significant and
serious change it is complex and will
require negotiations across all facets
of society whether it's with teaching
staff and their unions nursing and
medical staff and their unions it won't
happen overnight
however we have started and we have
started well
we are only at the beginning of possible
developments that can be enabled by
fiber capacity most future applications
we cannot even dream of today history
has been consistent history has shown us
that the bandwidth always precedes the
application innovation think about doing
everything we take for granted today
like Netflix and FaceTime or Facebook
live and do it on a one megabit
connection and see how you get on or
better again do it on a dial-up
connection the reality is that the
experience would be so poor that we
would never use those applications let
alone the billions of users that enjoy
them today the bandwidth had to come
first a fun fact to think about in any
given city the traffic that you will see
will typically consist of approximately
30% of cars that are looking for a
parking space it's a fairly simple
example but one that could have a great
impact on mobility in cities connected
cars will be great in themselves but
imagine the possibilities with traffic
management when the cloud has the
capability to detect congestion building
in a city and to slow down traffic from
entering that region similarly if the
cloud can alert the vehicles in that
area to freed up parking spaces that are
in close proximity to them the merger
between Internet of Things and much
better network capacity opens a range of
exciting possibilities some productive
some noble or worthy and some just plain
old-fashioned fun we should not seek to
anticipate history has shown it is
unexpected developments that have the
greatest impact and we must prepare for
them by having the right infrastructure
in place you know in the mobile space 3G
was starting to look like it was going
to be a failure until the iPhone came
along capability first then innovation
then development
so why fiber a lot of people observe
that Wireless solutions will develop the
last hop and data delivery I fully agree
for the record the world is going
wireless however when I look at a
wireless solution they all need to get
on to a fixed infrastructure as quickly
as they can and the faster the wireless
solution the quicker it needs to get off
the airwaves at the fiber-to-the-home
council europe we view our
infrastructure our telecoms network
infrastructure as an ecosystem and as
with any ecosystem there is
collaboration dependency interdependence
as well as rivalry and a richness of
interaction
however fiber fiber is the element that
underpins the overall telecoms ecosystem
it is therefore critical for the
well-being of our sector of our economy
of our societies that we move to fibre
to the home networks as rapidly as
possible to put it out its simplest
communications based on fiber optic
glass is based on pulses of light that
transmit ones and zeros of the digital
age as opposed to the electrical pulses
over copper or via radio wave in a
wireless context nobody is able to beat
the speed of light and hence there is
universal agreement that all fixed
networks will move to fiber some
question the speed at which this
transition will happen and in turn the
urgency of making such a move but that
transition is coming and it is
inevitable make no mistake the
importance of these relationships is key
Sweden moved first to 4G deployment in
Europe but in a study by their regulator
pts they found that the reason Sweden
moved first had very little to do with
the availability of spectrum and had a
lot to do with the availability of
backhaul networks backhaul networks that
match the capacity of the wireless
network namely the availability of fiber
we are doubling down on this
relationship in a 5g world there is not
much point in having Giga gigabit
capacity and single-digit millisecond
latency if you cannot backhaul us on an
equally performant Network so we need a
lot of new network we need a lot of
complementary Network investments where
have we made progress and what do we
need to do next it's important that we
recognize that the policy makers in new
European Commission have made a huge
shift in their thinking for years we
have complained of what we saw as fell
false technological neutrality where
nothing was said regarding technology
choice even though in every access
market in Europe we suffered market
failure in the form of dominance now the
Commission has moved to a true form of
technology neutrality it sets very
ambitious targets unless the
technologies choose themselves of course
we have the headline of gigabit
connectivity to all socio-economic
drivers and 100 megabits available
universally what is the specific
reference to fibre to the home and fibre
to the building or equally performant
networks that makes the real difference
in effect the Commission sets a
performance target by reference to fiber
and accept any technology that can meet
those targets these targets are in the
gigabit society communication but also
in legislative proposals that are
proposed as a formal target for national
regulators to aim for even the very act
of setting very high capacity at fibre
to the home or fibre to the basement or
its equivalent is important and has
direct and immediate consequences for
instance in my home country of Ireland
the government's National Broadband Plan
changed its network specification to
require fibre to the home we see the UK
is now allocated funding that
specifically for fiber to the home
others are following suit and we can
expect to see many more such initiatives
in the coming months and years
public funding is great and it can help
on the margin but it is the free market
in the industry that will have to do the
heavy lifting the legislative proposals
from the Commission are very positive in
our view and match the preferred model
for fixed access regulation very closely
the fiber-to-the-home Council Europe has
long advocated the tree step approach
firstly to set a fiber target and
specify geographically where competition
can work to spur investment and more
importantly where it cannot work second
is to enable a fiber rollout by lowering
the barriers to entry and this can be
true a sensible scheme to share passive
infrastructures and probably most
importantly to ensure that a solution
exists that deals with the in building
wiring third is to create the right
incentives for operators to build where
they can and this often requires that
virtual access remedies are removed or
at least greatly constrained we have
seen this model work in a large number
of markets each with its own variations
and peculiarities but each following
these basic elements and I'm pleased to
see these elements at the heart of the
Commission's new access regulation
proposals this bills and the work policy
makers have done in the last years
helping the industry to find ways to
reduce the cost of deployment through
the cost of cost reduction directive and
others we at the fiber-to-the-home
council Europe are very positive and
very supportive of those efforts and
particularly of the recent proposals and
hope to see their rapid adoption into
law does this mean that everything is
rosy of course not but I am very pleased
to say that we are moving in the right
direction and that there is a stronger
than ever momentum across Europe towards
fiber-to-the-home
good connectivity is not just something
for the rich it's not just for the low
key it's not just for the elite it's
something that every something for
everyone and we need to pay attention to
the digital divide society should not be
judged by the standards of those who
have everything it
should be judged on how it treats those
who are on the margins either
economically or based on their geography
we risk exclusion in the digital world
which may be even more dramatic than in
the analog world there were those who
are at risk of being excluded from a
democratic process that is increasingly
digitized those who are at risk have
been excluded from learning and
healthcare and all the other
improvements that a fiber-to-the-home
broadband network can deliver some seem
to believe the fiber-to-the-home in our
cities would be sufficient but this is
patently not the case would we deny
other essential services to rural areas
perhaps we'd force a lower electrical
voltage onto rural communities or better
again maybe we could get to your rural
communities to generate their own
electricity that make everyone's lives
easier wouldn't us no we wouldn't do
this nor should this be the case for
very high capacity connectivity we need
fibers of the home and we need it
everywhere fibre to the home council
Europe's deployment and operation
committee ran the numbers in 2012 on a
full fibre to the home network
deployment throughout Europe and rerun
the numbers earlier this year the cost
will be well below 150 billion euro over
the next 10 years and if we allow for
displace two other investments the
incremental capex will be very much less
than that number
ubiquitous fibre to the home is feasible
and we must not limit our ambitions the
new broadband platform in the committee
of the region's will leverage local and
regional initiatives while the new
connecting Europe broadband fund will
help to close the funding gap yes we are
calling for the right networks yes we
are calling for the right services as
well and yes we are calling for the
right speeds we're also calling for
inclusion because it's important for
everyone every European citizen to share
the means to improve their lives and
their circumstances no matter where they
are let me conclude with this
fiber-to-the-home can deliver a vision
of the
future which we will see exciting new
services deployed in a range of domains
driving Europe's economy forward in a
sustainable and progressive way we can
only truly rely on these services if
they are built upon the most reliable
networks namely fiber and we must
remember many network elements are
dependent on others so for example we
will not get 5g unless we have fiber
available to support that technology and
its promise of the future
the Commission has recognized this fact
and is legislating to accelerate fiber
investments as the body representing the
industry whose vision is to accelerate
fiber deployment for the good of society
we look forward to working closer with
policymakers to deliver this vision of
the future I'd like to close by once
again welcoming each and every one of
you to the 2017 fiber-to-the-home
conference and welcome you to your
future thank you
[Applause]